The London Underground has made more money
from its famous map than it ever has from
running trains.
In 2010, the Italian government had a fleet
of 629,000 official cars: ten times as many
as the US government.
Mars is populated entirely by robots.
Seven to be precise.
About a quarter of the world's hazelnuts,
100,000 tons a year, are used to make Nutella.
Sudan has more pyramids than Egypt.
More than a third of the world’s 43,794
airports are in the USA.
Starbucks offers 87,000 different drinks combinations.
The heart symbol was first used to denote
love in the 1250.
Prior to that, it represented foliage.
In 2012, a Somali Islamist militant group
offered a bounty of 10 camels for President
Obama and 2 for information on Hillary Clinton.
The dinosaur noises in the "Jurassic Park"
movie were made from recordings of tortoise
sex.
The first recorded incidence of air rage involved
a passenger in First Class who shat on the
food trolley after being refused another drink.
Eight of the Earth's 88 naturally occurring
chemical elements were discovered in the same
mine in Sweden.
The first known vending machine dates back
to the 1st Century AD.
It accepted a coin, then dispensed holy water.
40% of all bottled water sold in the world
is bottled tap water.
Humans have been hunter-gatherers for 99%
of their history.
The US has only 5% of the world's population,
but almost 25% of its prison population.